at the start of Game of Thrones ayuh
Stark is a rebellious tomboy she doesn't
want to be a noble lady like society
expects of her she wants adventure and
freedom
he loves her brother John he understands
what it's like to not fit in John gives
aya a sword called needle aya sees that
the world is unfair because of Circe's
cruelty and Geoffrey's lies aya loses
her wolf Nymeria and her friend micah is
killed so eyre starts to hate her
enemies Syrio Forel teaches aya to fight
and says the only god is death when war
begins with the Lannisters aya has to
leave Syria for dead and when a
stableboy grabs aya she stabs him ah his
first kill is this poor dumb kid io
lives rough in King's Landing for a
while then sees the execution of her
father Ned Joran takes her north and for
her safety aya pretends to be a boy
called Arry so in season one aya is
separated from her family and her
identity and moves towards violence and
death in season two aya makes friends
with Jan jury and Lommy and hot pie but
she struggles with trauma from the loss
and death she is sane her way of coping
is to repeat a list of the people she
wants to kill yourens group is attacked
by Lannisters a soldier called polliver
kills la me and takes needle eye is
imprisoned at Harrenhal where she
suffers and sees innocent people
tortured and killed she's made to serve
Tywin Lannister the man who's waging a
war against her family so aya has to
hide her identity and use her wits to
survive a faceless man called jaqen
H'ghar kills people for iya giving her a
taste of power and vengeance with
jackings help hire Gendry and hot pie
escaped Harrenhal jack and offers to
train Arya in Braavos but she wants to
stay and find her family
jaqen leaves aya with a coin and the
words of Valar morghulis
all men
must die so Harrenhal hardens are you
teaching her to use violence and cunning
to survive in season 3
our Gendry and hot pie are captured by
the Brotherhood without banners
the Brotherhood also captures the hound
and io wants him dead because the Hound
killed Micah
but the Hound wins his trial and goes
free
so again aya finds no justice in the
world aya wants a family of people she
can rely on but hot pie and Gendry both
leave her
so aya feels abandoned and alone aya
learns to use a bow better which might
come in handy and Melisandre visits
saying that she'll meet aya again but
then the Brotherhood betrays Gendry and
they failed to take aya home so I you
get sick of their [ __ ] and runs away
but then she's captured by the hound the
hound takes aya to the twins and for a
moment arya dares to hope that you'll
see her family again but they arrive in
time for the red wedding where Aya's
mother and brother were murdered Aya's
hopes are crushed again and all she can
do is kill some phrase in vengeance she
uses jackings coin and says Valar
morghulis so in season 3 aya learns that
she can't rely on anyone friends will
just leave her family will die and
there's no justice unless she kills her
enemies herself in season 4 our journeys
through the war-torn Riverlands with the
hound who leads her deeper into violence
and cynicism they fight some Lannister's
and aya kills polliver the first name
off her list she Avengers Lommy
retrieves needle and gets her own horse
to ride this is like the first good
thing that happens to Iyer in three
seasons and she achieves it by killing
when a kind farmer offers them food and
a job The Hound mugs the farmer aya is
furious but the hound teaches that this
is just the way things are the weak die
and the strong survive he says that hate
is a good motivation to keep someone
going so on one level aya hates the
Hound for
so brutal and callous but the hound is
also the only person who understands
aiya
the hound feels betrayed by his family
abandoned and alone with only hate and
violence to hide his hurt and that's
just how ru feels so Arya and the hound
care for each other when no one else
does
aya meets Brienne and she likes her
identifies with another misfit female
warrior but the Hound gets suspicious
and they end up fighting leaving The
Hound near death The Hound asks aya to
mercy kill him but IO refuses she tells
herself that she wants the Hound
to suffer but deep down I adjust doesn't
want to kill her only friend with most
of her family dead and with nowhere to
go
Arya uses jackings coin to sail to
Braavos maybe here she can find peace
happiness and family but nope she joins
a death cult in season 5 aya joins the
faceless men a cult of assassins who
worship death to truly join them aya
must become no.1 to give up her identity
all her hopes loves and hates so aya
those away the things that make her aya
accept she secretly keeps needle this
sword represents her family Winterfell
Jon so deep down are your remains a
stock aya works in the house of black
and white she sweeps cleans corpses and
gives the gift of death to a suffering
child she contends with the wife a rival
faceless man who doesn't believe that
aya is no one aya takes on the identity
of Lana and spies around Braavos Jack
and orders her to kill her first target
The Thin Man but instead ru goes after
Meryn Trant the Kingsguard who killed
Syria she follows Maren to a brothel
uses a faceless disguise and brutally
kills him another name off her list but
the faceless are mad because I not only
killed the wrong person but she did it
for her personal revenge when the
faceless men are meant to be no one
giving death anonymously as a religious
gift so the man who are you thing
is jackin kills himself but then another
man where's jaqen 's face because there
is no jaqen he's just a false identity
worn by the faceless man so in the most
confusing way possible are you losers
another friend and because i or wore a
face before she was meant to iron is
made blind season 5 plunges arya into
darkness in season 6 aya lives as a
blind beggar in Braavos the wife beats
her with a stick teaching her to fight
blind and trying to break her
psychologically to make her admit that
she's not no-one but Ayyappa cysts she
gets a training montage and fights with
sticks until she can finally hold off
the wife and Jachin gives her sight back
jaqen or desire to kill an actress
called lady crane and warns that this is
ayahs last chance to join the faceless
aya watches crane act in a play about
Westeros and relives the execution of
her father but she's also moved by
Circe's grief as played by lady crane
are your likes crane so she refuses to
kill her which means she's used up her
last chance for the faceless men aya
takes back needle gets a haircut and
books a ship home but then she's
attacked by the waif and almost dies
she's saved by lady crane so ayahs mercy
saves her own life for the first time in
a long time
I arrests and feel safe with a friend
who cares for her but then the wave
kills crane another dead friend
aya lures the wave to a dark room and
uses her blind training to kill her she
confronts jaqen and says she's not no
one she's aya stark of Winterfell and
she's going home so in season 6 aya
learns the faceless skills of deception
and disguise but she also returns to her
identity as aya and goes back to
Westeros aya kills Walder Frey and bakes
his sons into a pie and in season 7 aya
disguises herself with Walters face and
poisons a room full of phrase finally
avenging the rain
wedding but then she made some Lannister
soldiers and learns that not all of her
enemies are evil some of them ed sheeran
ayah meets her old friend hot pie and
they don't quite reconnect I is unable
to describe what she's been through her
experiences have changed her she runs
into a direwolf Nymeria and asks the
wolf to come with her but she doesn't
because Nymeria has changed become wild
and independent she isn't the pet she
was before
just like aya isn't the girl she was
before aya returns to Winterfell and
it's changed too
Sansa has become lady stark in charge of
the castle and bran has become a psychic
weirdo aya gets a Valyrian steel dagger
and makes friends with Brienne but Sansa
is disturbed that her sister is now a
killer and ire accuses Sansa of
undermining Jon for her own political
power all the sisters childhood
resentments rise back up and
Littlefinger works to divide them
further it gets to the point where are
you threatens to kill Sansa but in the
finale
the sisters finally unite and bring
Littlefinger to justice they learn to
respect one another and bond over their
stark identities so in season 7 we see
how the experiences that have made Arya
a powerful killer have also alienated
her from her friends and family if she
continues her path of vengeance will
lose her humanity what will happen to
aya in the final season of Game of
Thrones
there will be more reunions aya will
finally see John again she'll likely
reunite with Gendry and there could be
romance there Gendry likes to call are
you my lady
aya will meet Daenerys and she'll
probably like her aya has said that she
admires dragon Queens
maybe she'll get a dragon ride reunions
with the Hound and Melisandre and beric
will be complicated because they were
all on I is death list for a while will
is still hold those grudges there might
not be time for that drama because in
the season 8 trailer the dead attack
winter
fell and aya fights for the living with
her Valyrian dagger and obsidian weapons
she might kill a white Walker or two
maybe her ultimate test as an assassin
could be trying to kill the night king
bran gave her that dagger for a reason
but aya will want to finish her death
list and the last two names are the
mountain and Queen Cersei the Hound once
said that he and aya could kill the
mountain together maybe the Hound will
be wounded in this fight and aya will
have to mercy kill her friend but will
Iook ill Cersei aya was sympathetic when
she saw Cersei played by lady crane Arya
relates to Circe's feelings of grief and
anger so maybe aya will show Cersei
mercy just like she spared crane I is
actress Maisie Williams says that she
hopes that aya will let go of anger and
revenge to find peace and happiness
maybe aya can finally get the family
she's always wanted like she wouldn't
marry a lord and have 15 children that's
not her but maybe she could have a home
at Winterfell as Queen's Guard for Sansa
or for John or Daenerys or maybe she'll
go off on her own as an adventurer and
see what's west of Westeros she could
sail into the sunset like Frodo and Lord
of the Rings a sad farewell to a hero
who was never quite whole after what
they'd been through or maybe aya will
only find peace in death the whole story
is soaked in blood and loss and trauma
maybe when winter comes the lone wolf
will die alone in the game of thorns
books
aya is a walk like bran she can enter
the mind of Nymeria so there are cool
theories about aya dying but living on
in her wolf running with a pack the
books have a lot more magic and prophecy
than the show everything's darker and
deeper and more complex if you want to
check out the books you can get one on
audiobook for free right now by signing
up for a trial at audible.com slash ASX
audible has the whole Game of Thrones
series including the world book short
stories and the new history book fire
and blood
members can choose a free book each
month and if you cancel you keep the
books you can listen to audio books
while you drive or gym or while you
cross the Narrow Sea thanks for watching
please like and subscribe and comment
below which character we should recap
next we'll be doing weekly live streams
right after each episode of Thrones
season 8
thanks to the patrons including Ashley
Napoli Sarah pocket Milt Elise of all
Brian Meldrum misty specks we'll get on
hung you and Kristy Ramos and Vincent
right chunk : pah sick and nope Cheers